bubble
[Music]
what do you want me to do Jacob has
trouble telling his mum what he wants
did you want me to move out the way
he was born at the start of the first
covid lockdown and she says it has had a
big impact on his speech and language
we didn't do a lot because we couldn't
we could go to the park we could go and
feed the Ducks
but we didn't get to see friends and
family and that would
help with like hearing different
conversations and hearing different
words and and things like that but he
didn't he didn't get to do that he is
very chatty
but
I think we take for granted just how
much different social situations helps
communication Jacob can you say I
I for insects it's not just a problem in
early years education new figures
suggest that 1.7 million school-aged
children in the UK are struggling with
talking and understanding words
following the pandemic
children could struggle with talking and
understanding words all the way through
their SEC their school careers and
actually if we don't help them they're
more likely to fall behind in all of the
core subjects they're more likely to
develop mental health problems they're
more likely to end up in the criminal
justice system the charity wants the
government to fund better training for
teachers to help reverse the lingering
impact of covid children lost out on
lots of social opportunities and
parents were at home working from home
the parents might not have had the time
to kind of interact as often and it was
really a stressful time for parents so I
think it has had kind of a negative
impact but the research that I've read
shows that children will catch up so if
they're given the right tools and early
on
ghost oh my goodness a spooky ghost the
Westminster government says they're
investing nearly 5 billion pounds to
help youngsters following the pandemic
including targeted support for pupils
who need it most but some feel that
significant numbers of children are
still being failed
Lisa